In 2001, the state of Gujarat swore in
a new Chief Minister.
His name was Narendra Modi
and he's now the Prime Minister of India,
possibly the country's strongest
leader in a generation.
Evidence was very clear
that poverty had declined very sharply
during Mr. Modi's tenure in Gujarat.
This was of course the result
of a number of initiatives
that he had taken economy-wide.
But his rise didn't come without problems.
In 2002, over the course
of three days, deadly riots
by Hindus targeting Muslims
spread across Gujarat.
According to official figures,
over 1000 people were killed,
223 people reported missing,
and another 2,500 were injured.
Everybody attacked us.
Even the police.
They poured kerosene and acid
on us and set us on fire.
A narrative has been sought to be spun,
trying to paint Prime
Minister Modi and the BJP
in a negative light.
Critics say that the
buck stopped with him.
The local law enforcement
was his responsibility
and he let things go out of hand.
But the Supreme Court has
absolved him of all charges.
But the violence
in Gujarat was not an isolated incident
that only happened
under Modi's leadership.
It's one of many religiously
charged riots over the years,
mainly targeting India's Muslim minority,
which makes up roughly 14%
of the nation's population.
And it continues to this day.
Whether it is riots where
it has involved Muslims,
or Hindus, or Sikhs, or anybody else,
the denunciation is extremely explicit
by Prime Minister Modi and by the BJP.
But some leaders of the
Bharatiya Janata Party
or BJP, have also
explicitly promoted India
as a Hindu nation rather
than a secular one.
Critics accuse them
of emphasizing identity issues,
while turning a blind eye
to increasingly bolder Hindu groups.
All these things emboldened
the Hindu nationalists,
the fringe elements, and they're the ones
who undertake large-scale
rioting and lynching.
The popularity of Modi
has given allied politicians the courage
to enact new laws around the country
that explicitly discriminate
against Muslims,
most of whom don't support the BJP.
I strongly feel that the
government is sending the message
that Muslims do not
belong to this country.
Now some observers warn
that the BJP-led government may seek
to exploit religious divisions
to consolidate power,
at the expense of India's minorities.
The fear it has created among
the community is actually
the main monster, which is
driving the people to suicide,
to depression, almost
everyone is affected.
Although tensions between Indian Hindus
and Muslims existed for centuries,
they more or less lived
and worked side by side.
If you go back and read
the history, I mean,
the divisions were there,
but they were not explicit
or they will not cause for any friction
amongst the population.
But the British Raj had a strategy
that firmly separated them into groups.
It was called 'divide and rule'.
How do you control this
massive population?
You divide them along religious
lines, the caste lines.
Policies, including a separate electorate
for Muslims, led to rigid
religious identities.
This also allowed the British
to pit groups against each other
and consolidate their own power.
It was essentially
to continue ruling over
this large population
and large landmass,
and an area which was really
pretty productive, rich,
and helped the British Empire back home.
On August 15, 1947,
the great symbol of the
British Empire came down
for the last time,
to be replaced by the banner
of the new Indian government.
But in 1947,
when Great Britain decided
it could no longer afford
to be in India, it decided
to partition the subcontinent
into two independent dominions.
Pakistan, which also included
modern-day Bangladesh,
was designated as a Muslim majority area
and India was designated as Hindu.
The result was an unprecedented migration
of 15 million people, which
historians say claimed
between half a million and 2 million lives
in the bloodshed that followed.
I guess the contours of
that agreement was possibly
the biggest tragedy in India's history
because it led to the largest
migration of population
and it was pretty violent and bloody,
so thousands and thousands
of people lost their lives.
Hindus who moved from Pakistan
into India and Muslims
who opted for Pakistan as
their homeland in 1947.
The violent nature of
the partition created
an atmosphere of hostility
and suspicion between India
and Pakistan that still exists.
It also influences the relationship
between India's Hindu majority
and members of its Muslim
minority who didn't flee
to Pakistan during the partition.
It's very difficult for
a certain set of people
to forget that event.
You know, the Hindus
accused Muslims of doing it,
Muslims accused Hindus of doing it.
So, I mean, those divisions
have continued till this day.
But there were attempts by early leaders
to reverse this trend.
When India became independent,
the leading Congress Party
that included India's founding
fathers, Jawaharlal Nehru
and Mahatma Gandhi,
wanted a secular country.
They had envisioned a secular state,
where everyone is treated
equally, irrespective of caste,
creed, religion, gender.
Others disagreed.
Gandhi was assassinated in 1948
by a former member of Rashtriya
Swayamsevak Sangh, or RSS.
A secretive, all-male
society founded in 1925
that promotes India as a Hindu nation.
They are one of the biggest organizations
in terms of sheer numbers.
I mean, I would say they're present
in almost every district, if
not every village in India.
A young teenager named Narendra Modi
was a member of the RSS, but
later shifted to the BJP,
which is inspired by RSS ideology,
as a political organizer.
The way the RSS works is
that RSS loans or lends,
one of its key members or
leaders to the political party.
They generally have a fair
idea of the political lay
of the land.
So they guide the Bharatiya
Janata Party in a sense.
Modi moved rapidly
through the BJP hierarchy
in his home state of Gujarat
and became the state's
Chief Minister in 2001.
According to my research,
Gujarat had done the best actually
among all the large states of India.
You know, when he became Chief Minister,
Gujarat was ranked
sixth, by per capita GDP.
By 2006, Gujarat was already number three.
But a year after becoming Chief Minister,
the deadly religious riots occurred.
Gujarat chief minister, Narendra Modi,
has now given out an interview
in which he has said he has
done absolutely the right thing
in 2002 when the state was hit by riots.
Modi led Gujarat for 13 years
before turning to national politics.
Running against a Congress
Party increasingly seen
as corrupt and ineffective by citizens.
At that time, it certainly looked like
the congress-led coalition
government was not very likely
to return, but issue of course
was whether BJP could emerge
as an alternative, and that
required decisive leadership.
That is when the then Chief
Minister, Modi, decided
to enter the fray.
Modi capitalized on his image
as a strong leader to win the election.
He made bold promises that
appealed to the masses,
including bringing
toilets to all rural areas
and bank accounts to all.
I was sort of taken aback
that, "Is he going to be able to do it?"
But successfully he did it.
There was one week
in which he opened so many bank accounts
that it got into the
Guinness Book of Records.
Despite some unpopular
and highly criticized economic decisions,
other major reforms remain
popular among average Indians,
whether they're Hindu nationalists or not.
They want a very strong leader.
They want faster growth.
They want somebody
who takes quick decisions,
a government that's nimble.
But Covid-19 triggered
an economic slowdown,
as it did in most places,
and that required a non-economic strategy
to consolidate power.
Modi and his closest
aide, Amit Shah, pursued
a strategy of uniting voters
by stressing a Hindu identity
instead of one divided by castes.
An idea that could unite
all the caste-based voters,
creating a new majority that rules India
for decades to come.
Modi's even bigger re-election victory
in 2019 showed his ability
to appeal to the masses.
We are a party and we are a
government for every Indian
and the constitution grants every Indian,
irrespective of religion, equal rights.
After Modi's re-election,
the government scrapped
seven decades of autonomy
for the contested region of Kashmir,
the only part of India
with a Muslim majority.
The state of Jammu and
Kashmir was the only article
in the Indian constitution
which had the word temporary
in front of it.
Every political party,
including the Congress,
including others have
repeatedly said in parliament
and are on the record saying
that this temporary condition should go
and it took Prime
Minister Modi and the BJP
to have the political
will to make that happen.
And over in Assam,
his allied political leaders
are introducing new reforms
that seemingly single out the
large population of Muslims
that live there.
They were brought to Assam
from today's Bangladesh
by British colonizers, to
work in the agriculture field
to grow more food.
There was a section who do
not welcome these people
for them, they thought
that this is a threat
to their language and culture.
They persuaded the
colonial administration,
that there should be a demarcated area,
and this Muslim peasant
settled either in river island
or in riverbank areas.
When the partition happened,
they didn't go back to Pakistan
because they were already
integrated to the society.
They felt that this is their land,
and they were also very much
with the Indian nationalist
movement, which is very secular
under the leadership of Mahatma
Gandhi, Jawaharlal Nehru.
Assam, which is led by the BJP, compiled
the final list of the
National Register of Citizens
or NRC in 2019.
By verifying people's
documents the act aims
to separate genuine citizens
from illegal immigrants.
Proving citizenship is
difficult for two reasons.
One is that there are many people,
those who do not have proper documents.
And the number two is these
documents are not appreciated.
The NRC, a key feature of
the BJP's election manifesto,
threatens to render 1.9 million
people stateless overnight.
Most of whom are Muslim.
Although the NRC has affected
other Indian minorities,
as well as some Hindus,
non-Muslims have recently been
given a path to citizenship.
It's called the Citizenship Amendment Act,
and it was passed by
parliament in December 2019.
It prioritizes citizenship
for undocumented Hindus,
Sikhs, Buddhists, Jains,
Parsis, and Christians
from the neighboring
Muslim-majority countries
of Afghanistan, Bangladesh, and Pakistan.
The government describes these groups
as persecuted minorities.
India has an obligation,
has a moral obligation
and a legal obligation to provide shelter
to the minorities of these
newly created nations
because their original homeland was India.
Critics point out
that persecuted Muslim
minorities don't qualify
for citizenship under this act.
If they're coming to India,
if they are not Muslim,
then the government will
give them citizenship.
But if that person is Muslim,
then that option is not available
under this new Citizenship Amendment Act.
So this is a clear violation
of Indian constitution.
Indian constitution is
a secular constitution.
The NRC, along
with the Citizenship Amendment
Act, has only fueled concerns
that Modi's party is using the measure
to advance a hardline Hindu agenda.
To deal with the people rendered stateless
by the new laws, Modi has begun
the construction of camps.
With the largest one in Assam,
which will be able to
hold 3,000 people found
to be foreigners by the new registry law.
So far, five other facilities
have been constructed
with a push to build more.
To make matters worse,
the climate crisis has
caused some rivers to rise
in recent years, making
many of the Muslims
who have inhabited those areas
for generations homeless.
When they get displaced,
normally government has to
provide them compensation
but because of the societal
and political divide,
these people they are not
getting any kind of compensation
or rehabilitation from the government.
Now this government saying
that you are illegal
and crosser, and these
Muslims in a large number,
they have been evicted from their home.
But events in Assam seem to reflect
a nationwide trend.
Hindu nationalists are
building a temple in Ayodhya
on the site of a mosque
destroyed by Hindu activists
in 1992, an event that
triggered deadly riots
and remains sensitive for Muslims.
It was a mosque and the court has accepted
that the demolition was illegal,
but the same court has given
the land to construct a temple.
Modi laid the first
brick on August 5, 2020.
There have also been reports
of vigilante mobs attacking
people transporting cows,
which many devout Hindus consider sacred,
and new laws prohibit
the consumption of beef.
What I feel is
that this actually gives
some sort of license
to the vigilante groups
to carry out the crime like lynching.
We have already come across cases
where Muslim men are harassed
because of carrying beef.
And the Chief Minister of Uttar Pradesh,
Yogi Adityanath, led a campaign
that accused Muslim youths
of seducing Hindu women
to convert them to Islam.
This law prohibits inter-religion marries
between Hindus and Muslims,
especially Hindu women
marrying Muslim men.
These marriages are now made
illegal and the allegation is
that these Muslim men marry Hindu women
to convert them to Islam.
This is ridiculous.
At least one marriage was ordered
to be annulled by a court.
But support for the
Hindu Nationalism cause
is far from uniform across
India's Hindu majority.
After the Citizenship
Amendment Act was passed,
protesters of all faiths
took to the streets
across the country.
That gave actually some sort of hope
that there are people in the society
from the Hindu community
who are against this brutal violation
of Indian constitution.
Other critics also include some
of the country's most
influential billionaires,
as well as the Indian
diaspora in Silicon Valley.
Freedom House, a US-based
advocacy group, said
that among the world's major democracies,
India suffered the steepest declines
in civil and political
liberties in recent years.
There has been some sort of
resistance and resilience
among the community as well.
There are people within the community,
those who are supporting the
victims, especially those
who are facing this problem
of citizenship contestation.
We also see that, people
within the community,
they have started speaking
out about this issues.
So I think, along with this,
we have some sort of
positive story as well.
Although Modi remains popular,
India's democracy still
allows for citizens
to voice their opinions
and make a difference.
The backlash the government
faced after CAA led
to them developing cold
feet and they've kept
the National Register for Citizens
or National Citizenship
Register on the back burner.
The chief ministers of several states said
they would not implement the
Citizenship Amendment Act,
and nearly 2,000 academics
and professionals signed
a statement condemning the law
for violating the spirit
of the constitution.
While Modi still remains
popular, the negative reactions
to the new restrictions seem
to have given his government pause.
There are numbers of religious minorities
who are facing terrible
assault and attacks and rapes,
and murders and genocide who continue
to seek shelter in India.
So there is a demand that we
must do something about them,
give them shelter, but
as far as the CAA act
that you're referring to, which was passed
in parliament two years ago,
some people have already started getting
the benefit of citizenship.
And those who are eligible
that is till 2014,
who have come across as
refugees will get it.